[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
Culiacan, Mexico--
long considered one of the most
dangerous cities in the world.
Some of Mexico's most infamous
narcotraffickers dating back
to the '50s have come
from this region,
including Mexico's most
wanted drug lord, El Chapo.
Here, narcoculture thrives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Jesus Malverde shrine is a
popular attraction for tourists
and traffickers alike.
Malverde is a local legend
and Robin Hood figure.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Traffickers are known to
visit the shrine to ask
for Malverde's blessing when it
comes to drug deals, shipments,
even murder.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A visit to the local
cemetery is probably
the most telling example of
how Mexico's narcowars have
played out in Culiacan.
And it's the cemetery of
known narcotraffickers
where they construct these huge
mausoleums over the gravesite.
The family takes proceeds
of the dealer, basically,
and builds these structures
in honor of their death.
These can cost as much
as apartments here.
This one even has bars over
the windows and a central alarm
system.
Here, the dead are better
off than many are in life.
This mausoleum boasts a leather
sofa, an homage to a girl
and his Camaro--
and even bottles
of Ace of Spades champagne.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So many are so
young-- 18, 20, 21.
It's a generation
lost to a drug war.
And it seems to know no end.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
On another episode
of "Seeker Stories".
FEMALE VOICE: From pot delivery
services to marijuana yoga
sessions to high-end
dinners featuring
different strains of
weed rather than wine,
a new cannabis
culture is emerging.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: If you want to
see all your favorite "Seeker"
content three days
earlier, check out Vessel.
Follow the link
in the description
to get a free 30-day trial.